excited that I just get to leave this
for me now what did you do
hey guys welcome to the season two
finale of lotion translation
as always we take a recipe we put it
into Google translate it goes from
English to French to Japanese and many
many more and finally back to English to
give us a hilariously translated recipe
as promised we got lots of surprises
today we are doing a Lost in Translation
relay so this is how it's gonna work
we're all gonna be tackling different
parts of the same recipe not knowing
what the person before us did you might
have noticed Kelly's not here she had
her baby
leave her some love in the comments we
really really miss you Kelly but we have
a special guest helping us out today she
is our friend and fellow producer Laura
hey guys hi I'm so excited to be here
for the season finale to torture you but
for now get in your places wow I'm going
first right yeah
all right are you ready Katie I'm not
the president of pants
how many hints do I get well the three
of you guys get one hint like a shared
hint yeah so if you use your hand Nemo
and Jasmine can't use theirs if you use
your hand then like they're kind of
screwed great let's just do it let's
just get started step one meditate to
400. oil oil oil
and direct with the art newspaper oil
oil oil
meditate to 400 makes me think like
preheat the oven to 400. so I'm just
gonna deal with the first thing and I'm
gonna preheat an oven to 400. newspaper
might be like parchment we need to get
our parchment and we need to get oil or
butter oil spray spray whatever I do
here is going to be huge and I'm tempted
to take it so the girls are gonna be so
mad I think newspaper is parchment paper
it's really risky to take a hint here I
mean like I could get a lot of backlash
is it selfish maybe I just oil paper
have you done this before no I've never
done this
I think I'm gonna use the hint really
I'm gonna use the only hint Lauren and
you have to
draw it
box box sheet pan oh my God put
parchment on a sheet pan with oil yeah
they're gonna kill me so I'm just I'm
gonna do a full sheet I'm gonna oil this
wow I feel bad like I should have maybe
just like guessed that but it could have
been those but it didn't say Circle I
don't know step two get the answer the
snow is divided and there is a woman of
seven large beds into two large bags
okay the snow is divided is making me
think that it's sugar divided now I'm
thinking powdered sugar or could it be
like an egg is divided but it doesn't
say how many maybe oh maybe divided is
like it's
seven large eggs seven large eggs white
the egg whites are divided from the
seven large beds two large bowls ah two
large bags is two large bowls seven
large ladies their snow is divided egg
whites are divided into two large bowls
I feel good I'm gonna move forward with
that step number three using a wall
connector hit the blank potatoes with
tender excellent speed for six to seven
minutes until Phil's words appear who is
Phil who is Phil we may never know wall
connector I think is I wonder if I need
to beat them but do I need to beat both
of them
blank potatoes blank white egg whites
blank potatoes egg whites is Phil's
words Phil does he climb mountains is it
stiff peaks I'm gonna whip these for six
to seven minutes until I see Phil can I
take a while
Phil's words done step four engage one
and a half cups of you got soccer to the
bowl with the fruit and hit on average
until it is a bleak color and you are
exaggerating three to four minutes
you're exaggerating
no I am not this is hard there's fruits
soccer makes me think of ball there's
also lemons which is common in the
dessert which now I do think we're
making soccer ball soccer ball I think
we're gonna beat the eggs till they're
like a weird like a light yellow color
are the eggs the fruit the egg yolks or
the fruit but you've got soccer is that
you got sugar
is you've got sugar because I just want
to beat these eggs with sugar and I'm
gonna do it till it's a bleak color so I
think like a pale color I think Bleak is
pale it looks pretty bleak right now my
whole feeling is particularly perfect
step five keep the blender running on
tender low power the river adds half a
glass of water and mix until I love you
then add a half a cup of oil and mix and
match well River adds half a glass of
water I don't want to add water but
maybe I should oh a little whole milk
hanging out here all on its Lonesome and
I think some milk to this would be great
this could be wrong I'm so sure of
myself right now and then I'm not
tenderlo on low speed the river adds a
half a glass of water and then mix in
half a cup of oil I don't know this
looks pretty I like it and I won't have
to deal with it about three steps so
step six install a good filter over the
jam and be ready in one and three
quarter cups plus two tablespoons of
Cake Powder one teaspoon of malt
supplier two tablespoons of blood powder
oh and a boot of kosher salt oh well I
think a boots a pinch I think it's take
jam and put it through a sieve and then
one teaspoon of multiplier no idea it
sounds like a video game uh two
tablespoons of blood powder which I've
seen a lot of beet stuff over here could
be this beet powder it could be more
deep what's the difference blood powder
could that also be chocolate okay I see
jams here
sweet how much jam oh no
this is bad I'm gonna sift in Cake
Powder one teaspoon of multiplier
multiplier a multiplier it makes it
bigger it multiplies it it makes it
larger it's either baking soda or baking
powder because it makes it rise maybe
I've only seen baking powder here I'm
not seeing baking soda and two
tablespoons of blood powder I'm skipping
that for a second and a boot of kosher
salt I think it's a pinch of kosher salt
blood powder blood powder I'm just gonna
go with beet powder oh well okay it's
really nice that I get to leave the room
after this and not have to finish what I
started step 7 add lightness until it's
completely padded and feathered one to
two minutes oh
add lightness until it's completely
incorporated into this am I mixing it
again
I'm gonna fold it in I'm gonna first I'm
gonna just mix this together even if
this isn't correct but it just feels
weird that it's sitting on top and it
needs to be mixed that looks good that's
mixed actually not hating the color I'm
going to add this to it perfect looks
great never seen anything like this
before I'm sorry for any culinary people
out there going like what I'm excited
and I just get to leave this for me now
okay step eight she slowly moves up into
the crab using a financial rubber
foreign
okay I think this is the crap
crap using a financial rubber I
think I might have already done this
oh maybe at the lightness was add like
all the sifted ingredients I think you
know I think I'm gonna leave I think
it's time for me to tap out put me out
of my misery bring me more in and let
her know that I use this that's what I'm
living with see you next memo why am I
closing right here what did you do the
president of pants
[Music]
step 9 gooey in a stew pot and this is
an equal distribution so gooey is this
am I committed to this
I'm gonna assume Katie made a smart
decision and picking this but I'm just
gonna trust my partner I'm gonna dump
this and distribute it equally and now
we're gonna distribute it based on this
gooey
concoction I cannot say I'm set up for
success for that reason I'm concerned
step 10 bread in 15 minutes until he
takes a deep breath and then
intermittent toothpaste is pure open the
oven and how much is this this has been
a lot of fun I'm gonna let Jasmine take
care of it what does that mean I'm just
concerned do I bake this or chill it
because this oven is on we're gonna go
ahead and bake this for 15 minutes and
we'll see what we come up with Step 11
while the snow cake
prepare the cookie in a medium pitcher
connect one and three fourth cup of milk
one package of the vanilla three
tablespoon of thanks and two tablespoon
of corn starch hit and hold while the
cake bakes prepare the frosting medium
pitcher and medium Bowl oh look at that
we have a medium Bowl it's not milk
there's no way it can be milk because if
it's milk
do we have heavy whipping cream because
I do not see it I see milk we have
vanilla icy vanilla we have condensed
milk I see a lot of beets
wait do I get
it well how many hints as a group do we
get you all the three of you guys only
get one hint
does she use it already
you did I think I'm gonna use the hand I
made sure we got the right pan
all right guys
um I guess I'll move on with no hint
since we don't have heavy cream we're
gonna stick with milk one and three
fourth cup of milk okay one package of
vanilla oh oh
the package of vanilla packaged in the
pot
oh you're gonna cook it you're making
pastry cream three tablespoon of things
thanks thanks
you sugar
and two tablespoons of cornstarch so
we're going to add cornstarch and sugar
it's pretty much pastry cream and hoping
and praying the next step is cooking
step 12.
I just see cooked step 12 cooked and
brought over medium high heat it always
goes on with a tablespoon of flour until
special four to five minutes thank
goodness we're cooking this because I
would not want to eat raw cornstarch
always goes on until special and one
thing about pastry cream is it always
goes on you have to whisk it while
you're cooking it because you don't want
it to burn on the bottom we're gonna add
our milk mixture into this pot and for
the one tablespoon of flour we're adding
one tablespoon of butter and we're gonna
whisk it constantly I'm gonna keep
whisking this until it gets thick and
very special Step 13 remove the heat
source and move four tablespoon of not
salt until simple be calm
ah so I forgot something the heat Source
removed from heat not salted butter be
calm
all right we're gonna add more butter
because like we say in tasty more butter
is better I feel like I missed something
in the previous step where it said one
tablespoon of flour but now that it's
fully cooked I can't really add more
flour because it will taste not great so
we're gonna make a cornstarch slurry and
add it and cook it a tiny bit more to
thicken it up that way Jasmine has
something to work with see it's already
getting thicker I'm feeling much more
confident and I feel like I'm setting
Jasmine up for Success all right I'm
done and now it's up to Jasmine too take
us to a home run let's go get Jasmine
three two one
[Music]
what is that
the president of pants
step number 14 while the cold cookie
cut the ball
remove the ball from the skin and set
aside
use a two inch spinning cookie to hand
make as many parties as possible I feel
like I'm being asked to complete a math
problem but I don't know what the
problem is I've only seen a little bit
of the work oh
oh cut the ball remove the ball from the
skin and set aside and I think I will
remove this from the skin use a two inch
spinning cookie spinning cookie cutters
what size this
actually this
actually this
we don't know all right it says use a
two inch spinning cookie I'm so dumb so
I'm gonna make my parties and I'm gonna
make as many as possible step number 15
turn each cake carefully find more
information anywhere so remove each cake
carefully I'm getting Vibes that this is
sweet it looks like strawberry okay it
says turn them over but I assume that
means like take it out this is very cute
I hope we're making like tiny
multi-tiered cake so far so good all
right my parties have arrived find more
information anywhere
step number 16. add a tablespoon of sour
cream onto the underside of each pie
Circle and fill the circle with the
second cake and give me a sandwich
whoa demanding add a tablespoon of sour
cream oh sour cream oh so I think
earlier when I said flip it that's what
it meant all undersides are showing I'm
gonna now add whoa that's like pudding
oh
haha
okay so I'm gonna add a tablespoon on
the underside build a circle with the
second cake and give me a sandwich I
will give you a sandwich I guess I'm
going to continue doing this until I
have made many a sandwich okay all my
sandwiches are assembled step 17 expand
the thin edges of the pie with another
tablespoon of eggs turn around in the
one and a half cups of mashed cocoa
banana to wear over and over the rest of
the cookies
uh uh uh this is hard I think
I need a
hint what is happening Katie
the hint and she used it on the first
step so no hint for you no hint no
oh maybe it's like top Each pie with
some more cream oh you want me to spread
this on the side so I assume this is the
pie and you want me to frost the edges
they look extremely worried I hope I get
a ding check mark right now
I am frosting the sides with my globular
vanilla pudding and I will do this for
the rest so I will be right back now I
must turn around in the one and a half
cups of mashed cocoa banana to wear
vanilla wafers
mashed vanilla wafers we love whatever
you do we love support you we love
whatever you do thanks for me all right
I'm going with vanilla away first
yeah okay now I'm going to mash my cocoa
banana until it wear
transfer this into a bowl maybe over and
over the rest of the cookies so I'm just
gonna continue doing this for the rest
of my pies step number 18 in a middle
plate combine three quarter cup of cave
chocolate and two teaspoons of butter
Heat box for 30 seconds until completely
affected okay I feel so confident right
now three quarter cup cave chocolate
cave cave scary scary dark dark
chocolate dark chocolate two teaspoons
of butter I do believe is butter or oil
you've never been asked to give two
teaspoons of butter so it's most likely
oil
in a middle plate so that means like in
a medium Bowl so I'm gonna add three
quarter cups of cave chocolate I think
two teaspoons of butter is two teaspoons
of canola oil it's in there and now I
must Heat box for 30 seconds which means
microwave for 30 seconds until
completely affected which means soft
smooth and melted step number 19 Spring
a tablespoon of this special form on top
of Excellence let the chocolate melt for
about 10 minutes pour a tablespoon of
this special form let the chocolate
Harden for about 10 minutes or set so I
think a tablespoon on top and then just
let it drip around the sides on top of
Excellence should I spread it so it like
drips around the edge you know
[Music]
know so I'm gonna just do this for all
of my Excellence Excellence is done they
do indeed look excellent and now I must
wait 10 minutes to let the chocolate
melt which I think means let it set
Alexa set a timer for 10 minutes
step number 20 be patient I actually
have no patience I'm known for that in
my family I think be patient means to
Plate it these are looking beautiful
Katie mimo you want to join me for the
last step these look good I don't think
that this is what it looks I blame them
president of pants what do we think
beautiful yeah are you guys ready to see
the real thing yes
I'm kind of scared close your eyes
three two one
dude dude
outside we were talking and we were like
just say dude see there's no drips off
the side you did well though yeah so did
you guys I mean it looks very similar
and they are a cake-based dessert native
to the Balkans they're really popular in
like Albania Bosnia Serbia Croatia
they're so cute so should we try ours
first and then try this one yeah okay
cheers
huh
it's earthy it reminds me of like me
saying I want cake and my mom being like
you shouldn't eat sweets and then she
gives me this healthy alternative
teamwork nice job can we try the real
thing I'm dying Yes Papa
um the coconut adds a really nice
texture the cake is better but ours is
actually told like you could totally
serve that it would be delicious
that was really fun I'm shocked because
I took the one hint how do you feel I
feel like she could have saved the hint
for me all right guys thanks so much for
watching we hope you enjoyed season two
of Austin translation make sure to check
out shopbusbey.com to shop our merch we
got t-shirts and totes and mugs thanks
everyone bye
Maybe
it's gonna be it has to bake something
will be something will happen we spent
all season torturing me and you're gonna
take that all right
this with strong Foundation
[Music]